قالت مصادر محليه ان قوات الدعم السريع
اشتبكت امس الاثنين مع قوات عسكريه من
الجيش السوداني داخل مدينه الرهد بولايه
شمال كردفان السودانيه واوضحت المصادر ان
قوات الدعم السريعه اثرت اثنين من قوات
الشرطه داخل مدينه الرهد بعد ان تحركت من
منطقه او منطقه اوم سكينه القريبه من
المدينه
واشارت المصادر الى ان عده مباني حكوميه
احترقت بما فيها مبنى جهاز المخابرات ان
القوات الدعم السريع انسحبت خارج المدينه
كما شهدت مدينه الجنينه غربيه دارفور
اشتباكات ايضا بين الدعم السريع ومجموعات
مسلحه سقط على اثرها نحو 200 قتيل خلال
يومين وقال حاكم اقليم دارفور ان المكونات
الرئيسيه والاهليه في اربع ولايات باقليم
دارفور قررت عدم الدخول في اي حرب
مبادره ولايه جنوب دارفور مبادره كان
الشامله
وشملت كل المكونات جنوب دارفور من الشباب
من طلاب من الرعاه مزارعين موظفين المجتمع
المدني المتقاتلين من الطرفين وجميعهم من
الحكومه الرسميه والادارات الاهليه من
ناحيه الشعبيه جميعهم اتفقوا على ان توقف
هذه الحرب العباسيه واتفقوا على ذلك وايضا
نفس النموذج تم تطبيقه في شمال دارفور
والان
البندقيه سكتت في شمال دارفور بشكل كبير
ونفس النموذج تم تطبيق في وسط دارفور
وكذلك ايضا في شرق
نظام مراسله الجزيره هيثم اهلا بك اذا
اشتباكات جديده تسجل في منطقه الكادرو
يضاف هذا الى اشتباكات اخرى في اكثر من
منطقه هيثم كيف تتابع كل هذا
هيثم هل تسمعني
هل تسمعني
هيثم نعم اسمعك نعم كنت اسالك عن هذه
الاشتباكات في الكادر وتضاف الى اشتباكات
في مناطق اخرى كيف تتابع كل هذه الامور
نعم من الواضح ان الاشتباكات والمواجهات
تدخل شهرها الثاني وما تزال موجه هذه
المواجهات مستمره في مدن الخرطوم الثلاثه
سواء كان في الخرطوم بحري التي هي الان من
اشد المناطق التي تشهد هذه الاشتباكات او
الخرطوم اجزاء منها او حتى اجزاء منهم
درمان احيانا ولكن اما يدور اليوم في صباح
هذا اليوم هي اشتباكات في منطقه الكدر
وشمال بحري هذه الاشتباكات تدور بالاسلحه
الثقيله والمتوسطه او الخفيفه كذلك نوع من
المواجهات المباشره في تلك المنطقه ايضا
في ذات الاسماء تدور مواجهات في منطقه شرق
النيل وهي المنطقه التي ايضا شهدت بالامس
اشتباكات عنيفه في تلك المنطقه والان ايضا
تجدد القتال في المناطق الشرقاني في منطقه
الجريف شرق تحديدا والمناطق المحيطه بها
هذه المناطق التي ايضا تقع في الجزء
الشرقي من النيل وبها الطريقه الرابط بين
الخرطوم بعدد من ولايات السودان سواء كانت
الشرق السودان او ولايات وسط السودان
الجزيره وايضا
الازرق وكذلك شرقا الى القضارف وكسلا وبور
السودان وايضا هناك العديد من كانت
المناطق التي تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريع قامت قوات الجيش بالطيران بالامس
بقصف مواقع لها بحسب ايضا بيان اصدره
الجيش في تلك المنطقه ويبدو ان عمليه
المواجهات البريه ما زالت مستمره في تلك
المنطقه ايضا في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم هناك
ايضا بعض المناوشات التي تحدث من وقت الى
اخر هذه المواجهات هي تاتي في خضم ما يجري
الان سواء كان الحديث عن التفاهمات ما تم
في جده بحمايه المدنيين وتجنب الحاق الضرر
بهم في المناطق الماهوله بالسكان او فيما
يخص ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه للمتضررين
من هذه المواجهات وهذا يبدو انه يصعب الان
الامر على تنفيذ هذه البنود على ارض
الواقع في ظل هذه المواجهات المحتدمه
الجاريه الان طبعا هذه المواجهات تاتي بعد
يوم حمله او جمله اقالات قام بها قائد
الجيش رئيس مجلس السياده لكثير منا
القاده العسكريين او ايضا في مناصب مدنيه
شكرا لك